hello from alaska we are still here
we've been here for the past two days
we're still shooting and honestly this
view up here
it's just like breathtaking it really is
there's anchorage down there
and there's some crazy
mountains
over here
so
hi from alaska
and no there's not any snow surprisingly
the weather has been amazing
karen's picking berries
oh rock and rebecca are also picking
berries
and there's uh drew and jared
all the way over there getting ready to
shoot
so the real question is guys how are the
berries
are you really eating
them no i think i'll be all right
actually
well okay i'm gonna try one
i'm gonna try
oh it's like a little tiny baby grape